but thank you all so much for joining
this call today I want to talk a little
bit about I kill that seems to be what I
talk about the most and this big
phenomenon about ransomware some of the
biggest entities that are being hit our
health care and financial anything with
personally identifiable information or
credit card information those are the
things but if you have an ITIL framework
in place I want to try to show you it
says 10 highly guarded steps with it's a
lot more than that obviously to being
able to use ITIL framework to protect
your organization against rent somewhere
now obviously simply mine is a company
that I belong to their course where and
I think it's just phenomenal for ITIL
and if you do not have a background in
ITIL or an understanding of I tility
should definitely check them out my name
is Manuel Lloyd to a little bit about me
I was homeless for the first 16 years of
my life I went in the united states
marine corps when I was old enough to
make money I got out of the Marine Corps
I started my business and I've been
doing this for about 30 years now the
only thing I think that's really special
about me is I've come up with this
formula here I don't think that's too
much for special but I've come up with
this formula here about operational
efficiency and it's worked for me for
the past 30 years and it fits right
within the framework of ITIL so I want
to just point it out about myself if if
you guys are going to talk more about
that and about how that applies to I
tool we can talk in the community forum
let's begin ok so I have a guy here
pointing a gun at you and his hand out
holding your ex you know he wants to
give you your data back after you pay
encryption key well that doesn't always
happen believe it or not and the bitcoin
is untraceable pretty much and the
people get away with the ransom you know
a lot of people say businesses are no
longer safe rest where is quickly
becoming the largest IT threat to
critical data but I say data is no
longer safe they could care less about
your business anymore they want your
data in space this is what we're going
to talk about it how we can use one of
the big one of my favorite pieces of the
ITIL with such as community service
community service management so let's
get into it I got this graphic here from
ABG which is a ad company that's very
interesting because now there are they
have a stream of their AV their
antivirus program that looks for and
protects and detects wrenchingly and
it's pretty cool so let me just kind of
read this infographic here talked about
Reza we're a growing amount of small
demeaning chocolates is falling victim
ransom lisha software in a coded
computer and its data evidence now this
is a big problem for those highly
regulated industries because our federal
government in the US it leaks I don't
know about some of the folks who from
the other countries but in the u.s.
there are heavy heavy heavy fines for
not protecting data as a matter of fact
in the health care industry you can get
fined up to 1.5 million u.s. dollars for
every medical record that has been
breached that's a lot of dough so
looking at these numbers here the
400,000 settles a wrestler they told 1.2
million new samples Justin one in 15
alone there's 60,000 new locking
infected computers in the 20 to 24 hour
period and if you are not familiar with
the lock you virus
thank God for that because you don't
want to be I've had some clients that we
my team I had to help with the lucky
bars issue they did not have an IPO
framework I won't say what framework
they did used but they didn't have i
till and i truly believe that they would
have had an ITIL framework within their
IT systems their financial systems in
their line of business operations they
would have been okay because that's the
framework that we use to mitigate the
problem this 325 million dollars USD in
damages caused by one form of ransomware
business called the crypt of wall
worldwide and here in the US the FBI
it's pretty much on cracker you know you
really can't do too much with it but I'm
gonna you know share something with the
FBI maybe they should look at I kill it
so the average ransom is between two
hundred ten thousand dollars but I've
seen a lot more recently a medical
facility out in hollywood california
hasn't paid three million dollars to get
their data back and that was really
ridiculous 27 million dollars estimated
ransomware paid by the untraceable
currency in bitcoin right now that's a
lot of money for a lot of nonsense so
again I animate I till horn shower if
you I'm a cheerleader for ideal I love
the framework I always have even when it
was a british standard very standard
fifteen thousand or so or something like
that so let's go to the next slide so
it's this is not a us thing you know you
see all of these countries here that
have been affected by the lock virus so
the lucky cryptolocker and it it's all
over the world of course because of the
internet you know if you've read if you
read some of my paper some of my white
paper some of my articles i'm not a huge
fan of the internet believe it about i
love it for what it can offer but at the
same time i find a very toxic very
unmanaged and www
really stand for World Wide Web anymore
it stands for wild wild west if you will
that's right you know a Western return a
u.s. term that we use all the time but
it's a big big problem all over the
globe so don't just think that it's just
here in the US or there in India and
Singapore or South Africa wherever you
may be it's all over the world okay I
want to thank rebecca lockhart to you by
the way for providing these info
practice orly they were helping my
presentation really well my presentation
can get kind of boring sometimes so I
need some help you know a lot of
organizations say well this doesn't
really apply right I mean we're really
definitely you know send me some percent
of small businesses that have 200
employees or less of the number one
target of hackers and if you have the
money if you have personally
identifiable information or ethi like
trying to protected health information
you are a target and you're easy target
because they use the smaller
organizations to rap on to the larger
organizations again it's just this
connected world that we you know you can
look for in my opinion that the Internet
of Things would be the next big wave of
hacks where cars and watches and just
just just you know cyber terror of
anything that's connected will be hacked
because hackers are very very very smart
a lot of people don't don't recognize
that and you have to be very careful
that's why I was so important to have a
framework in place my guy till you catch
to have governments that's going to be a
top-down bottom-up approach why'd you
name it broadened death I feel hazard so
you know according to global research
eighty percent of small businesses do
not use data protection which is crazy
because they think they're too small you
know over half of the small businesses
use email protection while resting where
is mostly spread via email so those
other fifty percent are you know you
click on it it says it's a letter from
your bank
it looks like and their people they
think they're going to get a million
dollars or a billion dollars from
somewhere there's all out of the blue
olive subsidy mail and they don't
realize what they're doing years ago I
wrote an article you know sitting here
in the US you know loose lips sink ships
I don't know if it Ridge inated hear us
but we used to hit it all the time but
you know loose clicks lose your mouse
clicks sink entire business you know you
click on something you can seek your
entire business everything's about
transactions right you press ENTER you
click that's a transaction so employees
within the US they're almost four times
more likely to click on the list link
within an email because we're just so
curious over here we just are so curious
and not just over here anywhere you know
ransomware attacks they have a
significant negative impact on
businesses and organizations and since
they are not always able to cope with
ransomware costs resulting damages can
put them out of business and so you have
to be really careful with that let's
move to the next slide here effective
business up time you know I'm a big big
big promoter and advocate of no.02 no
downtime as much as possible to raise to
zero downtime is something that I have
my clients look at and manage the cost
for you know in today's business
environment times money it always has
been you know research here among 300
respondents of this research for maybe
gene within business of all sizes show
that the documented downtime after an
attack could be more damaging than the
actual attack itself here's why let's
say you have a client or now I have a
client that's making a main and office
day every hour every single hour that
that let's say eight hundred thousand
because I'm not agreeing that petition
every single hour that this organization
is down there losing a hundred thousand
dollars
every single hour how do you mitigate
that how do you overcome that you know
72 hours is the average number of hours
the victim has to pay the ransom for
rent some winter seventy percent of the
infected businesses can't access their
data for at least two days so if you
take a million dollars that's two
million dollars you've lost the net in
those two days because you can't see
clients you can't keep patients you
can't see banking customers you can't
see you know people not leave a shop you
in your doors are going to be closed and
thirty-two percent lost access to more
than five days and in the US there's a
statistic that if you lose your data or
access to your data after a certain time
period more likely within the next two
years you're going to go out of business
and that's a horrible thing because no
one wants to lose their job or think
about someone losing their job so just
you know just think about this and I
would love to have discussion in the eye
and me are sipping learn community forum
about this to get some of your awesome
and we're leave some time for questions
as well so we're going to talk next
about how all risks were works this is
really really simple you know you
receive an email attachment you open the
email attachment a macro infect your
device plus the entire network god
forbid if you have network shares or you
have you know rdp or if you had you know
roaming profiles or something like that
and your windows network you know your
next thing you know what amor you
usually receive a pop-up that says hey
we have your data you have this long to
pay it and this is how much is going to
cost to pay and you have to pay it this
way you know the FBI in the US and our
telling people don't pay the ransom well
if the FBI going to provide that
business with revenue for those days
that they're download our hours at their
down so you can see the problem here is
the FBI's been being advanced as well
you know though don't pay a wrestler
what was what's a business supposed to
do well we're going to talk about that
because you don't have to theater in
every client that we've worked with so
far who's received any kind of rescue
we're having not paying a dime they paid
zero dollars and I think I till frame
for that so you make the payment and you
hope you're hoping that you're going to
receive your on the encryption key to
unlock your data but sadly that doesn't
happen all the time and if it does what
stopping them from doing it again this
is the reason why the FBI says don't pay
because I'll just do it again you know
we're going to talk about how you can
use the IPO framework there's many
aspects of the ITIL framework but i'm
really going to talk about 12 quite a
ransomware and always with it so with
protection like for instance this ad
company like AV gmail is doing they're
providing a stream of their antivirus
software that will allow you know
end-users to protect themselves against
them so if you will so they click on an
email attachment this AV software has a
smart engine that allows it to recognize
that this is a ransomware of attack and
the message is quantity so now you've
averted a lot of downtime a lot of
embarrassed because you know it's just
not the downtime when ransomware hits
it's also the chemistry reputation is
the embarrassment just the employees
that you're paying ten thousand dollars
for a break to stand around the water
and toilet thumb to talk about last
night's basketball game or football game
or TV show and it's also if you're in a
highly regulated industry like
healthcare or financially then there are
fines that you will have to pay their
security incident reports that you have
to give depending upon the number of
records that were breached or whatever
the case may be if they work so um so
the problem is that most businesses are
ill equipped to respond to rest now I
want to introduce a few of the current
problems that are tied to rensselaer and
there's no secret all of you out there
hopefully know that the best way to
fight risk where is with a good backup
right what does that mean you know
what's a good backup me I should be a
backup or really
continuity is like a cave right so you
have the flower you have the icing the
frosting you have the sugar we have the
edge you have the milk all those things
are key ingredients to the one cake
that's going to be at the end so when
you're a level executive or your
director says well you know that's going
to cost too much money one of the things
you want to share with them is that I'll
back up simply is not enough having a
good backup is one good way but Iration
where is more of a disaster and you need
to think about a disaster so the
solution is going to be something that
is in my opinion and my pain has a
weight because it worked so far over the
past 26 years and so I want to talk
about some of the problems know that
because disaster recovery a lot of
people say to disaster recovery but you
have to be careful with that language
because especially business continuity
because you have to look at that
language you have to have a plan that
maps out what true disaster recovery or
what true IT service continuity is so
you know I want to introduce a few of
the current problems with disaster
recovery methods and the current trends
that are propelling for the growth of
what people now are calling dress a
disaster recovery of the service right
you know what when we talk about
disaster recovery as a service for
instance we're talking about cloud we're
talking about cloud right we're talking
about data in the cloud and people go
well my gator house is more secure in
the club and it is here on my premise
well does your premise have a of diesel
fuel generator this yours have built a
great security biometric security the
whole nine yards that you have with a
data center that more than likely you
will not be able for slot to sock level
type of data center so having it in the
cloud I had this question
leap from one of my clients and yet it's
more safer in the cloud that it is on
your premise because someone to break a
window reckitt in your building snaps
your eph I from one of your hot swap
drives and they're out of town okay and
boom you're done you're done for your
multiple close your doors so I believe
that the solution is I to lucky service
continuity man okay having this
discipline this is one of the
disciplines that are in the IPO you know
whether you're 2011 or version 3 you
still have to have business continuity
and disaster recovery so let's get it
right into it so we're going to talk
about the problems with traditional
disaster recovery the five must-have
there's a lot of appliance out there
that they call cloud film over
appliances one company in particular
that I have looked at and I said a lot
of companies more of my clients we have
a very agnostic approach we don't sell
hardware software necessarily but we do
vet these vendors and one binden I found
to be phenomenal and Gartner even gave
them a cool vendor award but if you look
at their product it's not just cool it
happens a very complex situation which
is this is continuity and disaster
recovery and then the name of the
company improv scale infr asta le you
may want to give them a look and see if
they can you know give you a demo or
something but their product provides
backup on friend back up on in the cloud
and disaster recovery wouldn't apply so
we're going to talk about that those
cloud apply and fellow cloud fill over
appliances and then we'll have some
questions and answers okay but virtually
every business will experience some type
of downtown you know pervasiveness of
downtown there's some stats not one
percent of those sir they have had a
data center outage in the past 24 months
forty-seven percent of companies
experience analysis or downtime this
year alone and most people think that
you know the biggest downtime issues are
those that are natural disasters now I
live here in North Carolina which it
rather the coast right on the beach
which is hurricane alley we haven't had
a hurricane knock on wood any years but
we've had several disasters with several
organizations because of either hardware
failure and the human error and I think
this human hair is more than this twenty
percent that shows hardwoods there it's
natural because it's hardware it's a
piece of equipment and besides and I
hope no one gets sells hardware it gets
mad at me at this next David let's play
it obsolescence they're going to fail
anyway too because we want to say some
more metal right so the biggest
misconception is that it's some major
disaster that's going to happen you know
it doesn't take a hurricane to take you
out it doesn't take a hurricane to take
you out so and then look as a matter of
fact these statistics and I'll get the
source for you I mean I think this uh by
quorum but I'll get that source where I
thought I put it in there but I didn't
but looking natural disasters five
percent five percent you know on and
human error and heart failure are huge
in software failure is lower than human
error in that amazing that used to be
not the case years ago so make sure your
price I'll take it down time is
expensive and cripples any business you
know what's your cost of downtime you
have to calculate all the employees that
you have plus the revenues that you
generate plus overhead that it takes to
run your business and you calculate that
on a daily rate and some of these
statistics right here show that our
downtime costs per hour from an Aberdeen
survey calculated the average cost per
hour of downtime for all respondents
that they surveyed on this the average
downtown Koffler about 163,000 dollars
small companies lost over eight thousand
dollars per hour medium-sized firms loss
over 215,000 dollars an hour and large
organizations reported over six hundred
thousand dollars per hour in losses now
if you're an employer company and you're
going wow that's a lot of money i wish i
could make that you know the
your fact is that when businesses moves
down time it's everybody everybody's
part to play a role and disaster
recovery and business continuity not see
service continuity management because
when the business is down and they lose
money guess what more likely you won't
get paid so if your incentive to have
skin in the game to make sure you don't
click on something that could cause a
disaster you don't do something that can
cause a disaster and you're just being a
little bit more careful well actually a
lot more careful in these days because
cyber attacks are something that are on
the rise they're not scaling down okay
so there are various to on-demand
failover all right cost is one big
barrier they're very expensive you know
you don't have enough IT people so you
have to outsource you know they're
complex and compatibility issues one of
the biggest things that you will hear
more of AI think coming in these next
few years and we've been talking about
it for many many years it's
interoperability things just don't work
together i use a mac and i used
microsoft software and I've never seen
I've never seen so many if I had to pay
a fee every time my Microsoft Office
applications crash I'd be broke okay so
and i have a mac and you know it doesn't
crash like you know like that so it is
just something I'm not used to and I'm
not one of those met cult guy I just I
just like being able to work you know I
have eight years that it wise not to
take care of so I I can't have this
Valentine so again these came from
actual tech media these these numbers
here and I can share more with you in a
question-and-answer session so here the
trade-offs to do traditional D all right
you have all side backup which is not
that expensive but it could take days
weeks and sometimes even months to
actually get to the point where you need
to be and remember those days and weeks
or months costs dollars that cost the
business that could cost the
the business of clothes that can cause
you to lose your job you know but if
your ITIL certified though I'm gonna go
this plug-in here I have to it's just
too funny I doubt if your ITIL certified
from from [ __ ] train from from simply
learn then you'll have high demand if
that happens bhagavate it doesn't happen
but you know the point is you know get
get the gifts to get this train so then
you have cloud backup everybody's in
love cloud back no I'm going to cry over
I can do this now it just causes a
another word for hosting right i mean
that's all it is so you but you take
these innovative companies like a DG and
infra still who have come together to
make this thing more than just about a
cloud backup and about a virus
protection they're making involved
business continuity now all right so did
you have an appliance back up you ok
we're doing better but you can see all
the costs escalate as the time in
restoration it's a smaller time that you
want the smaller window or the RPL RTO
that you want the more it costs so
you're going to get you a breaking point
here right but then you have a cold side
dr when you have a place that you can go
drop off your equipment and start all
over again and build that column to that
cake that could take a week so it again
there's that money that you're starting
at that calculated starting to run with
the downtown then you have a warm side
view on with everything is there all the
equipment's there this it just has to be
stayed ain't knowin to the exit that
cost and but it it takes less time for
downtime then you have a hot side then
you're getting into companies who cannot
afford any downtime they lose millions
of dollars in minutes so they are they
can afford to pay the higher dollar
because they need to have their their
data back right away you take a company
like Walmart and they have a major
disaster from some kind of a pandemic
worldwide they're losing billions of
dollars every minute and they just can't
afford that so the cost of having a hot
side dr it is peanuts they need want to
get to d.r AAS
s all right the natural cover has a
certain nirvana what if there was a way
to be able to recover your site recover
your data for less money and in less
time you know that was one of the things
I was really really impressed with and
i'm not trying to sell you anything here
but that was one of the guys really
impressed with with Empress kale and I
bet it about 20 companies 20 companies
so far 4dr as a service who also have an
appliance who also does back up so that
we have an integrated solution that's
interoperable across the spectrum of the
entire enterprise and in an epic scale
met those criteria and those of other
ones out there that met them as well but
this one here I just really really
really impressed with a cheaper product
l on this call so dr or disaster it
comes should be on demand right so the
end-users working lon you know they
copulate I'm doing my word looking at
youtube facebook whatever okay and then
they run into a problem so servers and
applications are down you know in this
situation parison end-user you know
they're working but unknown to them that
they're not about they're about to
experience an unexpected disaster so
disaster happens the red X symbolizes
the disaster when their servers and
applications go down in there right in
the midst of an outage you know you're
the one that has to deal with this if
you're on a call more likely how do you
deal with it what do you have on prem
that you're going to bring the system
back up what are you having a cloud that
you're going to bring the system back up
and I just bring it up just say oh we
brought it back up again you have to
think like a c-level executive you have
to think like a business owner and say
how much money are we losing every
minute this is down what kind of urgency
do i need to put into this so you have
you know you're redundant servers they
come back online but if they fail so and
you still have the situation so you want
to have a disaster recovery that can
take minute
the second you know maybe an hour at the
most because the window that you're
dealing with in the case of a million
dollar a day company let's just take the
case of an eight thousand dollar an hour
company you want to try to get that down
to four thousand dollars or three
thousand dollars or two thousand dollars
for one thousand dollars you can't do
that with traditional dr systems you
just can't do it I've looked and I've
searched the world over and you just
can't do it so you want to have
something that the user sees maybe 15
minutes of downtime 30 minutes of
downtime no more than an hour and you
want to be able to have an appliance
plus software plus a cloud partner that
can help you with that ok let's talk
about the five months hands of a
disaster recovery solution ok so number
one you don't want to break the bank ok
traditional systems they break the bank
you want to you want to exploit cloud
spillover you want to get a complete
coverage you'll have something that I'm
dumbing here and others are even w here
as push buttons failover you just push
the button and boom you fail it over you
know and then of course you want to
encrypt your data I know companies that
take tapes off-site mass devices
off-site servers off-site and the data
is not even encrypted and it's sitting
in their car or whatever the case may be
so let's talk about number one we don't
want to break the bank traditional dr is
very very expensive you know to
implement now you have your production
site you have been would cost people
call software costs and then you have
your favorite smell your site what could
cost you up to three times the money so
the very expensive implemented complex
the test and use because you have to pay
for tests you have to set the test up
you have to do all of these different
things that is really crazy and then it
messes up your RPO and your artios your
recovery point objective in your
recovery time
and they they're vulnerable to hackers
number two because I want to get through
this here and you have some type of
questions we want to explore cloud fill
over you know this is the second secret
to finding a vendor with Klaus girl over
you know why by the appliance you end up
filling it up and then buying another
plunge you rip it in place then fill up
again and you continue this cycle ok so
that's really the only way of doing
things we're more space equals more
appliance there's a different way to do
this you know you want your goal to be
where you can scale your dr in a manner
that aligns with your business
objectives and when you're using an IPO
framework and IT continuity service
management I just service continuity
management then you're going to be able
to take all those principles y'all know
some guy I like the old ITIL away but
you know I'm fine with the new idea
where as well but you want to take those
scenarios you want to do a business
impact analysis you want to do a threat
and risk assessor you want to do a
contingency plan you want to do a
dependency plan and you want to write
out your entire business continuity plan
and make sure that you have everything
that you need to execute that plan in
the case of a disaster from from from
the time the disasters thought that
happened to the time you close out that
business continuity plan that you're
working on so the old way is more
spacing for more appliance the new wage
is one we want to use the cloud more
spacing for more cloud you can scale the
cloud much faster you can still a piece
of metal so you want to get complete
coverage number three okay you want to
be able to back up any device desktop
laptops physical or virtual servers you
want to support any other operating
system you want to be able to deploy in
any form factor that you need you want
to be able to store the any cloud that's
out there you know so it shouldn't
matter you want to be able to recover
anything broken machines application
servers whole nine yards
you want to be able to boot anyway can I
blue ticket from the clock can I move
from my place you want that versatility
of it doesn't matter what happens we're
going to bring our data backup and then
you want a film back of any certain
rotary machines application service
network the whole nine yards that's just
the simple way of doing it and there are
ways to do this in a cost effective
manner and it starts with your education
of business continuity disaster recovery
service continuity of management and in
my opinion in my opinion I feel is the
best way for any IT systems you know
there are other frameworks out there
like lean six sigma you know cobit all
those things are great but I found I
till to be the better framework so you
want to push but the failover right and
I got a soul this information I didn't
steal it i sold this terminology from
that coming in still because they that's
what they tell is a push-button spilled
over but you want to be able to no
matter what you use you want to be able
to support all environments boot
anywhere and you want it to be wickedly
fast and the course the obvious you want
to encrypt your data right data is
encrypted with with the user it stocks
at the users you want to be able to have
an encryption scheme kind of like the
ransomware people have an encryption
team you know you have to be very
careful with this encryption key because
if you lose it you won't be able get
that data you have to restart the whole
process all over again but you want to
take that in cricket you want to take
that business continuity plan you want
to put it in a safe and lock it and it's
for your eyes only kind of thing you
know you want to have your data sent
through 26 bit a 256 bit ssl and you
want your get to remain encrypted at
rest inn at the data center so let's
talk about the top 10 ways to prevent
ransomware backup your data often backup
your data often backup your data often
now if you have metal then this gets
difficult because you run out of space
you have to pay more money so that's why
college a very very good thing to have
in this
you want to train in your users to
exercise caution train your users
because people people people people are
what make the girl around right well
people also what make mix ransomware go
around two so you want to educate them
to make sure that they're doing the
right thing uses a repertory company
software and firewalls you you know
these free when I go to these clients
they have these free antivirus programs
on their network and you know they don't
they don't respect the you lure
agreements the username and user license
agreements they they have these free
tools in the week we have antivirus and
then they get angry when the antivirus
doesn't do the job that they thought it
would do because they thought they were
being sneaky and not having to pay
anything well they end up paying anyway
it gets worse because that the BSA ever
found out they were using software
illegally or they broke you agreements
they can get fine HIPAA violations come
on with that federer banking regulations
come along with that and it's just
really honestly I don't might use this
word but it really is stupid to not have
a reputable ad baby company and not
having license we won't even work on any
organization has software does not
licensed we will not even work on it
they've got to get that fixed first or
we have to pay us to fix it before we
leave I've found a BG to be a very
reputable company I use them i recommend
them I'll be totally transparent about
that but they are very rare when they
first came out way way way back in the
day I was excited to see the Sterling
company doing something I think they
were born out of Germany I think they
was out of Canada now but they they are
very reputable company you want to have
a separate windows for your backup and
your matter what skinny so you don't run
up into each other and they slow your
network down slows the backup window
down you just come in that day it can't
work it can't operate the network's
congested and it just makes for a poor
poor decision making of course if you
have an IPO training or background you
will realize that because you
go through the whole cycle I too and you
should talk to the people from I of from
simply learning about getting trained
then you want to have patch management
when you patch it update your software
always you know love Microsoft hate
microsoft they are the leader in
software operating systems and business
productivity tools but their software is
very vulnerable and it needs to be
passed constantly okay so i have a patch
management system you don't have one you
know throw me a note or something like
that in the community forum and i can
give you a list of different
organizations that i vetted that i think
are good and i think you will too number
six so hidden file extensions know that
way if you see something that says not
locking you know windirstat is a good
tool to use windirstat that goes and
find out with locking viruses are those
files are what's been locked us
encrypted or not so you can know what to
restore from your from your backup but
you know again if you have a good dr
solution though you're going to be able
to have a test environment out there to
go out there and play with it bring your
environment back up see if it works and
push button filled over it on at least
here for skill it does that you want to
go throughout the year keys and the
email disabled files running from app
data and local app data folders this is
really really crucial step number eight
here disabling rdt i know people love it
to death but i disable it and you want
to enable pop up blockers okay so now
those are those of things to do it to
prevent it but what happens if you do
get you know five things to do if you do
get affected by resler you want to
remove the infected machine from the
network immediately you know not just
you know delete the files and try to
bring it back though remove it
immediately from the network and you can
even if you have a big network just tell
the users unplug the cable you just go
in and remotely disable the network
connection you want to reset your Bibles
time this is going to count a trick the
lock you virus until you have time to go
in and mitigate the problem going to
roll back from a previous backup and
again it's not just back up
is back up disaster recovery emergency
mode operations hold on ours you wanna
stay current on the latest threats has
obvious and you want to alert the
authorities to discuss wrestler is a
crime it's an actual crime so you want
to let the authorities so and what and
one of the biggest things in the
ransomware again it goes back to money
and I till has financial management
systems built into it to help you model
this but getting down to the
nitty-gritty down to the details our p.o
or recovery point objectives are huge in
a locking arms are a ransomware attack
so let's talk about that real quick I
don't have like a couple more slides and
I will open up for questions the old way
of doing it is you know you restore from
a previous backup right this is what a
cloud backup solution okay a regular
cloud backup solution so you restore
from a previous backup you start the
most current backup you make sure you
scan them for viruses on another pc not
going that's in fact that you want to
check out files and folders that contain
viruses and go back the previous version
once clean version is found restore the
file folder there's a pros and cons the
only pro that is really is ideal when
the individual files or folders are
infected but what if you need to scan
files and folders are attached by the
clean copy how long does that take how
much downtime the clock is running
remember the money is kicking them the
clock is running you know another
confidence it's not effective at the
entire service infected so a better way
to do that is with disaster recovery as
a service so you know you spin up the vm
with your most recent image okay you log
into the booty the image to verify it
does not contain viruses you won't
expect it if the virus is tom go to the
next most recent it now the pros and
cons of this there's only one caller
it's much faster inspect the whole
system is intact users can access
applications immediately and you can
keep vm 17
the other two games the only drawback to
it is you know you must have a disaster
recovery solution that can boot on a
local appliance and you go out there
looking so far I've only found one I'm
only found one and that's how infra step
so now my last slide is always this
slide other than the questions is here
are the things that are going to be a
monitor modernization lesson for you
when using IP IP service continuity
means you should be able to identify
focus on the highest value activities so
don't just think about we'll get to that
bar that lucky that ransomware infection
as soon as we can no it should be your
highest priority you want to be able to
serve as multiple customers with varying
requirements using only limited
resources you want to be able to define
a measure and report relevant metrics to
help effect that decision making you
know having a management tool that tells
you about your network tells you about
your environment you want to have
blameless reporting that telling those
and so I won't go through all of these I
think you'll get the slides um so this
is my my saluting to fighting the
locking or the ramp any kind of
ransomware and if you use ITIL and I've
only talked about IQ service continuity
management a little bit because this
just you can't talk about all that in
one hour but it's more than just like a
service continuity management it's you
know service desk this problem
management its configuration man to
change men's release men all those
management disciplines that are involved
in operational efficiency for your IT
systems don't just deal with your IT
systems they deal with the entire
business and go to the things you have
to think about as a c-level executive as
an IT operator or as a nike network
engineer whatever it takes me p so i'll
leave it open for questions now and that
the model ready to take back over and i
hope you guys have enjoyed i said so far
and I'll take your questions now okay I
ask you a question here
kendra a solution have suggested scale
to large global companies 40,000
employees for example what is the
current trending draft solution for
global companies at the moment cloud
base ah i have not had the privilege of
working with a global company like that
i have work with autozone walmart target
their global companies but a draft
solution for a global company is
something that has to be scaled out
modeled out your biggest issue carl is
going to be as you already probably no
connectivity so there's a five things
that always talk about which is
infrastructure connectivity mobility
performance reliability so connectivity
is going to be your biggest issue there
you can take a solution add rastan for
instance and i'm using epic scale i'm
not going to be ashamed about that i
just found them to be a great company
they can take each one of your global
locations and do what you need to do for
each business unit and use an
operational efficiency model that's
going to align those departments or
those functions with the business
objectives of the entire organization so
if if the problem that you are running
to it doesn't matter what you really use
your problem is going to be connectivity
now I know Citrix has you know something
in the realm of s VLAN or SD a
software-defined wide area network or
software-defined Network where you can
use bonding technology to have multiple
cheap if you will connections just like
rain right so you have your done an
array of inexpensive disk you can have a
redundant rate of inexpensive ISPs or
internet connections and and and you
share those cross something right Cisco
coverage or riverbed to to hammer your
connectivity problem but the draft
solution that your tab I don't know if
scale is going to be any more important
on any other particular side other than
connectivity I hope
your question en could you remind us of
those suggested vendors you mentioned
4dr back up etc yes I look at a lot of
different vendors a lot of different AV
companies and so far so far knock on
wood the two that have been successful
for me that's three that I'm working
with Empress scale is one of them
they've done a really really good job
for drass disaster recovery has a
service but when you need to get
something done really quick and get it
up and running and get it moving I had a
client that I needed help on weekend and
they were able to get me 10 terabytes in
no time and get that client backed up
and have a dr solution and process you
know there's another company out there
that I work with locally here I don't
know what their international presence
is I think when you guys to hear from
Asia but you can talk to them their
course 360 guys name is rich venom that
you can talk to Matt let's mess with us
from the mat from Memphis scale I forget
his last name now he's going to kill me
which is bad for Matt from Memphis kill
and then Rebecca Lockhart is a person
that I've worked with at ABG who has a
really great monitoring to a really
great AV for our ransomware attacks
those adventures and does it ask you a
question in only got party a question a
sense okay cool so wouldn't the focus
also be at having some controls yes and
that's what I till gives you miss
control I shall give you control from
the beginning to the end in my opinion
and I've been doing this for 30 years
and so far not one single client has
ever had to pay a ransom has ever have
to pay a hacker anything not a dime I'm
knocking on wood right now because I
look at the Gartner reports I look at
the forestry research reports event the
vendors very very strongly through our
own processes that was that formula that
I had in the beginning of slide at 0 e
equals States
to the Y to the v why that's a kind of
my secret sauce but yes you have to have
controls there's three things that you
have to focus on especially when you're
a large company is compliance IT
governance in cyber security so the
controlled come from the entire
framework of IPO and my opinion because
it starts with your service gets it
starts with the end user customer saying
hey I can't do X and the number one goal
of ITIL is to get the customer back up
and running it in a business as usual
environment so yes those controls are
involved now you get down to the
nitty-gritty same cool on ransomware and
IT service continuity management there's
their frameworks within that and I don't
want to steal the thunder away from
simply there and I think you actually
look at their look at their their their
curriculum and look and see not going
through their curriculum on their IPO
and I was really impressed and I was
doing the first people in United States
to get ITIL certified and I was really
impressed with their coursework so I
definitely would look to look at maybe I
don't know if they offer a sample or
demo but look through the course work
and you'll see what those controls come
in and the service continuity management
piece yeah and yeah you have to have
stronger pros that's why I said it
begins with the user right so you have
to you have to be able to train that you
to make sure that they're not doing at
me because strong controls am I going to
do anything if someone clicks on
something you know it's akin to you have
a house that you're in you and your
family are in the house and you have
several kids like me or I have a kids
right so if someone comes and say I'm
here to see one of your sons and I go
okay without vetting that person we're
asking my son you know this guy then I
was the one that allowed that guy into
my spear home I'll lock my door let man
in if that guy comes in and does
something you need was how do you
control that you have to have a
protocols in place then beyond just
software you are in school I like your
name too sand cools i hope i pronounced
it right thank you is it from which data
centers you are referring
are you asking me where I've got the
information from or are you asking me
okay yeah I got this information from
two sources I have information from the
resources if you look on the slides
there from the different groups like
quorum but I can give you the names
emails of the people that I work with
met Calvin and infra still and Rebecca
Lockhart at ABG to globally recognized
companies done a lot of research they
work in this space and they provide a
big provided products i vetted them also
if you're in the states and they're
there to let in Georgia or out norcross
georgia a company called chorus 360
chorus co r us 360 my contact there is
rich benin all that helps funny cool no
problem
you